good afternoon everyone I'm Gary
Tomlinson the director of the Whitney
Humanities Center and I want to welcome
you today to the first of two
finzi-continis by distinguished
indologist and political activists David
Shulman before I turn the podium over to
the introducer of our speaker I'd like
to say a few preliminary words about the
finzi-continis each year one of the
highlights of Whitney Humanities Center
programming the finzi-continis ship was
endowed in 1990 by the Honorable Guido
Calabresi judge of the US Court of
Appeals for the Second Circuit and
former Dean of the Yale Law School and
his brother dr. Paul Calabresi
in member in memory of their mother
Bianca Maria finzi-continis Calabresi
we'd oh and his wife Anne well guido
is-is-is could not be with us today but
his wife anne Calabresi
is here and I'd like you to join me in
thanking them in their generosity and
their family for their generosity
[Applause]
and tells me that they had a delayed
flight back from Italy and only got in
at 2 o'clock last night so and and and
Guido is teaching right now so a busy
busy life Bianca Maria finzi-continis
was a scholar of European literature and
a native of Ferrara she fled fascism in
Italy along with her husband dr. Massimo
Calabresi
and settled here in New Haven she earned
a PhD in French at Yale with a
dissertation on French and Breton
historian ernest renan she became
professor of French and Italian at
Connecticut College and then was for
many years professor and chair of the
department of Italian at Albertus Magnus
College she died in 1982 at the age of
80 passed finzi-continis have included
Amitabh gauche
Dino Mengistu Maxine Hong Kingston or on
pom oak Suzan Stewart and many other
distinguished writers and scholars after
the election of the lecture today got a
pragmatic note there will be a reception
in room 108 which is straight down the
hall behind you outside the outside the
auditorium and you're all invited to
join us there and tomorrow afternoon
will convene again at 5 o'clock to hear
the second of Professor Shulman's
lectures and finally curiously Yale
legal counsel instructs me to announce
that this lecture will be video recorded
I'm instructed to announce that because
apparently people need to know that so
that they can be responsible for their
actions and their actions and so in any
case now you know you're being video
recorded be careful how you act
at any rate introducing David Shulman
today will be Phyllis ground off flex
Hickson professor of Religious Studies
here at Yale professor ground
[Applause]
so Gary warned me that I better be
careful and leave enough time for
David's talk and it's been a challenge
so many are his accomplishments it's a
great honor for me to offer these brief
comments about David Shulman a longtime
friend and colleague and I speak for
everyone in the field of ontology when I
say that this his scholarship has been
an inspiration to all of us David is an
enormous ly productive scholar and I
don't know of anyone else whose work is
so thoroughly animated by the love and
empathy that he feels for classical
Indian culture whether he's translating
poetry writing about theatre singing
classical Indian music humming the
depths of Indian philosophy or exploring
the history of Tamil language we know
we're in the presence of someone and
something exceptional for whom
scholarship is joy and in whom the
wonder of discovery never lags in
everything he does his indefatigable
energy and never to be satisfied
intellectual curiosity are a source of
marvel some of you may have heard David
speak on Monday so that you know he is
also deeply committed to social justice
and often writes on contemporary issues
affecting Israel the Palestinians and
the world this in all of her in addition
to all of his many contributions to in
dollar G over the centuries India has
given us many saintly scholars they led
remarkable lives and enriched the world
in many different ways and so it is with
David and as one might expect in the
life of any Indian scholar st. the
wondrous events began at his birth in
David's case what was so unusual about
his birth was the place Waterloo Iowa a
city that seems never to have recovered
from his leaving it it's population has
been in steady decline since that time
home to the John Deere tractor and
engine museum it would seem at first
glance to have been an unlikely place
for one of the most extraordinary
scholars of our generation to have
chosen for his birth but the wonders
continue I do not know if like the
ancient sage ashtavakra David recited
the Vedas while still in the womb but I
do know that soon after he emerged into
this world his prodigious appetite for
learning became apparent david would go
on to master many languages among them
hebrew in which he is a celebrated poet
Sanskrit Arabic Tamil Greek Russian
French German person Telugu and
Malayalam just to name a few
David won a National Merit Scholarship
on graduating from high school and he
emigrated to Israel he entered the
Hebrew University graduating in 1971
with a BA in Islamic history with
concomitant focus on Arabic language and
literature and African history he roamed
the world again like a sage of old and
completed his PhD from the School of
Oriental and African Studies in London
this time working sanskrit in tamil for
many years david taught at the Hebrew
University where he chaired the
Institute of in Asian and African
Studies he also served as director of
the Institute of Advanced Studies and
has been a member of the Israel Academy
of Sciences for many years David's many
honors include a Guggenheim Fellowship
grants from the National Endowment of
the humanities and a MacArthur
Fellowship in 2016 he was honored with
the Israel prize his country's highest
cultural award this puts him in the
company of such luminaries as Martin
Buber and Zubin Mehta he has received
honorary degrees from the University of
Chicago and the University of Hyderabad
although officially retired David
continues to move the field forward in
new directions mentoring young scholars
and pursuing research in 2017 he was
awarded a European research
council grant on the new ecology of
expressive modes in early summer in
south india work in progress includes a
book on theatre another book on music a
study of models of mind and existence in
medieval south india and a study of a
temple complex in maharashtra david's
publication career began with his
dissertation telmo temple myths his
first book was published in 1980 and it
would be the first of some 30 books that
he has written co-written or edited it
remains a classic in the field and a
book to which I refer my students as
something to which they might aspire
like many Indian sages David has the
power to make his audience hear the
words of poets and philosophers in their
own language
the poet or sage speaks in Sanskrit or
Tamil we the audience hear it in English
this is truly what transpires in his
translations of poetry from Sanskrit and
South Indian classical languages
directly immediately almost magically
these poems appear to us in our own
language as if to defy the very notion
of translation as somehow a pale
imitation of an original if we did not
know that these are translations we
would never suspect that the voice
speaking to us is not the poet's own
such as the vividness such the immediacy
of his translations like a sage of old
David loves mysteries he has written
about riddles about the god Shiva smih
Styria scheme of dice a book that itself
is playful in the best sense as it moves
with a dynamic flow between opposites
inside and outside male and female
delving the very mystery of creation in
his hungry God he confronts the mystery
of a God that demands the ultimate
sacrifice of his devotees the sacrifice
of a child and it in his most recent
work more than real he delights in the
interplay between real and fiction that
so that Indian dramatist and poet is
so so loved india's given us many wise
men some were reclusive and withdrew
from the fray others sought to found a
community of like-minded seekers and
David belongs to the second group
throughout his career he has created
opportunities for students and
colleagues to learn together and with
him over a period of 10 years he brought
students to Kerala each year to study
the theatrical tradition could he anthem
kodiak them like many traditional art
forms is under stress with the loss of
its patroness if this extraordinary art
form survives it will be to a large
extent because of David's efforts in
bringing it onto the world stage and
into the academic and critical discourse
of contemporary theatre David is an
extraordinarily generous colleague and
teacher many of his writings are the
results of joint efforts he loves the
gut give and take the sharing and while
he shares his knowledge through
everything that he writes he also
somehow finds time to work closely with
students everywhere reading their thesis
answering their questions on email his
energies boundless his accomplishments
truly larger than life I am grateful for
his friendship and guidance over all
these many years and so pleased that in
his sage-like wanderings he has come
here for this week to share some more of
his insights into the mysteries of life
and artistic creation please join me in
welcoming David Schulman
I'm a little speechless after that
introduction and I have to say I found
it a little hard to recognize myself in
what Phyllis was so generously saying
except for the part about Waterloo which
was exactly correct I often say that I
was born in a place more exotic and most
of the places that I roam around in in
the world and but on the other hand I'm
kind of proud to be from Iowa believe it
or not Phyllis thank you very much I
want to thank everybody who had a part
in my being here today
the Whitney Humanities Center its
director Gary Tomlinson Phyllis true
self Sandra in the officer was fantastic
with all of the arrangements and above
all and Calabresi for the endowment of
this series it's a great honor for me to
be here and I'm very happy to meet her
it's a particular kind of happiness of a
lot of friends in this room some
long-standing friends and some more
recent friends I'm happy to be speaking
to you today so I'm gonna launch right
into it because we don't have that much
time I'm going to be talking about time
so here goes deep in the vast desert to
the west or maybe to the east now is the
mysterious City of the Dead with two
towers of fiery copper rising over walls
of black stone no map will take you
there you can only reach it by getting
lost on your way to somewhere else
intent upon another mission but once you
are there it becomes clear that this
city was the real goal all along you may
not leave it alive for that matter how
alive were you when you set out
we don't really know who if anyone
founded it but we do know that it bears
the footprints and the fingerprints of
King Solomon the wisest and also perhaps
the most foolish of men and it has a
name
or rather several names it's called the
city of copper we know it from the
Arabian Nights
the great historian eben Hal do not
enter fide it as cgl massa so those of
you who saw the mimosa film just you
know an hour ago you were looking at
some image of the city of copper Hamas
is a medieval entrepot at the edge of
the Moroccan Sahara and though and you
could also see those of you saw the film
that this now-defunct city which at
seven metal walls can still carry the
weight of a wondrous and fatal journey
I'll be saying a bit more about this
film tomorrow usually however this
strange goal for unwary pilgrims is
called following the version of the
Arabian Nights medina de Rojas the city
of copper or more commonly and some of
the like the canonical translations of
the 19th century is sometimes called the
city of Grass there's a kind of
sensitive point here but in my opinion
it is actually about copper in Arabic
brass is called a new Hassan Espanyol Oh
copper and actually copper itself has a
very venerable and prestigious genealogy
in Arabic okay also in the Bible you may
think of the copper serpent that Moses
made long ago in another desert and it
could heal from snakebite anyone who saw
it and that serpent had a name he was
called new host on copper ii and he
survived for centuries in continuous
worship by the children of israel until
King Hezekiah his Keauhou
had it pounded to dust as we know from
the book of Kings and the Koran tells us
that Allah made a fountain flowing with
molten copper for Sulaiman Solomon but
we digress as happens to all who
approach the city of copper itself by
definition and necessary possibly
terminal detour or digression we don't
know if the city of copper was included
in the oldest original version of the
Arabian Nights if indeed there was such
a thing as an original version which I
have to say I doubt I'm not going to go
into the textual history of this story
it's very complex it's also very
fascinating people give their entire
scholarly lives to exploring the text
reality in the Arabian Nights what I can
tell you actually two things one is that
it does exist in the 18th century late
medieval 18th century recensions what we
usually call did say the Sultan burger
give two sugars in see on these
manuscript recensions became the basis
of the first printed editions of the
Arabian Nights in Bullock in Cairo in
1835 and but we now usually called in
McNaughton or Calcutta to version 1839 -
1842 these printed versions came
directly out of these late medieval
Egyptian recension so that we know that
the story as we know it and I'm talking
about a literary version of a story
about the city of copper that story
existed by the 18th century and probably
a bit earlier maybe much earlier because
there was an Armenian version believe it
or not of the literary texts which
apparently goes back to the 10th century
there's a fine essay by James Russell at
Harvard about this
anybody wants to read it I'll come back
to that maybe in a little while we also
have a Judeo Arabic version of this
story
from the Ganesa there is a scholar in
Israel young scholar called go date
zinger who's working on this now now
it's not yet firmly dated probably
something like the 15th or 16th century
and you know there's another Judeo
Arabic version that is Arabic and Hebrew
letters it was printed in Bombay at the
towards the end of the 19th century this
is how it is with the Knights these
things begin to proliferate the story
exists in other Islamic languages
especially Persian that's important to
me for reasons that you'll see in just a
moment there is a person translation by
somebody called Mohammed bakufu rosani
prepared for the English resident in
Hyderabad
Sir Henry Russell in 1810 that version
may be the source of the Tamil version
of this story which is a mid 19th
century version I have to say at least a
few words about this at this point
because that in a way was my entry
ticket into this story actually working
on the city of brass that took me back
as somewhat nostalgic late to the years
when I was studying Arabic in person at
the university I was happy to see that I
could still more or less read Persian
and the film that some of you just saw
was also an important trigger in what
has become kind of an obsession I'm
hoping to write a book about this story
one of these days a short book but the
Tamil version has a specificity in the
particular interest about it so let me
just tell you this is in a kind of
proleptic manner because I'll only be
able to talk about the Tamil version at
any length tomorrow but I would like you
to know even before I tell you the story
which I'm going to do in just a few
minutes you can before I tell you this
story this Tamil version was composed by
a very famous Muslim Tamil intellectual
and author he is usually called Imam and
Aras although he's also called Mohammed
bin Laden
by alum he lived on the southeastern
coast of the tamil country at a moment a
very considerable cultural efflorescence
his name means son-in-law
naruse which seems to be a back
translation from the Tamil or Malayalam
would not be light which is the caste
name for many South Indian Muslims its
collective title but actually mama
Lawrence was indeed a famous son-in-law
who inherited and expanded his
father-in-law's renowned madrasah he was
a successful hardware merchant and more
to the point he was a prolific author in
both Arabic and what is called out of a
part of me is Tamil written in Arabic
letters I can tell you from experience
that the Tamil alphabet is not suited
sorry the Arabic alphabet is not suited
for writing Tamil it's something very
difficult to learn to read but this was
the script the Tamil wisdom is actually
usually used until rather modern times
and this RV version of the city of
chopper which is called Tana Department
in Tamil was written we think in 1859 it
wasn't published until 1900 by his
grandnephew published in Sri Lanka some
two years after the death of imam allah
rose and you know what that initial
addition in RV seems to have disappeared
completely I at this point know of no
surviving copies but he work was
reprinted in this time in Tamil script
in 1979 in Sri Lanka in a slightly
modernized Tamil that fits the text
reality of the Arabian Nights this work
damn old version of the city of copper
actually appeared on my desk in
Jerusalem one day that's thanks to the
services of Charlie Hallisey is here who
Charlie said in motion I think a kind of
worldwide network of scholars and
librarians and spies and other such
people and eventually a single copy of
this book turned up in a small library
in eastern Sri Lanka at a place called
Auto Ville and it's - thanks to Charlie
into the kindness of the librarians
there Muhammed Newman and Mohammed Majid
my chauffeur in all oval that this copy
actually arrived on my desk one day and
I think it's an extremely interesting
version of the story you'll hear more
about it tomorrow there's another thing
I have to say that is that this camel
version of the story of the city of
copper is very probably the first
example we have of modern literary Tamil
prose prose there are other kinds of
prose in Tamil some of them quite old me
of the prose of the commentaries there's
prose of 18th century Diaries
there's epistolary posed some of it
recently published by hermann Tekin
there's the prose of a kind of I don't
know what to call it cook village
narrative mode this is called Cavalia
Katoch in tamil that exists but modern
literary prose literary prose that's
always a discovery or something between
an invention and a discovery and it may
not be my chance that it is this
particular story that was chosen by imam
LaRue's for his experiments with
literary Prue's so that's important as I
hope to be able to explain tomorrow by
the way you know I just explained how
these camel versions have become
exceedingly rare we found only one copy
others seem to a banished entire
but there's an odd kind of literary
karma that attaches to this particular
story of the city of copper things keep
disappearing vanishing forever for
example there is or at least there was a
critical edition of the Arabic text from
the Knights by somebody called abu bakr
should ie was published originally on
the website of the university of
eight-cell called provence
but that website no longer exists and
there seemed to be no extant copies of
this edition at least I've not been able
to see it and that's only the first of a
long series of such disappearances I'm
not going to go into this at length now
let me just say that it includes the
important treatise on time
by a philosopher called medieval
philosopher called abu bakr al drazi
arguably the most acute intellect in the
entire history of medieval Islam he
wrote a book about time which
disappeared but and it's very relevant
to this story as I hope to show you
tomorrow we have a few fragments that
miraculously survived they were
connected by a scholar by the name of
Paul Krauss that's the name that it's
possible at least that some people in
this room might have heard Paul Krauss
was a great genius of Arabic and Islamic
Studies he published a brilliant
addition of these surviving fragments of
abu bakr al a z in the early 1940s in
egypt and in 1944 he committed suicide
in egypt if i do actually manage to
write this little book about this story
i'm going to dedicate it to the memory
of paul cross there's actually something
a little spooky about the story
altogether and strange things happen I
can tell you if you're interested in it
but let me
let me I think now just try to tell you
the story okay now I assume any of you
know the story it's a very well known
story one of the most well known and
beloved also perhaps the spookiest of
all these stories of the Arabian Nights
borefest
love did it has a kind of long liya
afterlife
you know after the Arabic versions even
if you know the story I think it's
probably not a bad idea for me to tell
it to you in a kind of telescopic
version so this will take about 10 or 15
minutes I imagine it could be that just
telling you the story might be the most
important part of this lecture today but
I do urge you to read it and I urge you
to read it in Arabic because it needs to
be read in Arabic when did you get a
feel for it in the course of telling you
the story I'm going to read you a few
verses from time to time you'll see in a
minute why that's important so the story
is set in the distant past at the time
of the Umayyad caliphs the Maliki bin
marwan in Damascus and he hears one day
during the kind of storytelling that
happens at the court he hears that
fisherman somewhere have been hauling up
in their nets these odd copper bottles
or containers clacking and if the
fishermen break open one of these models
then what happens is that a genie issues
force screaming at the top of his voice
at Talbot Talbot on Azula forgiveness
repentance repentance or Messenger of
God I repent of everything that I did
just don't put me back into that model
again and people know that the reason
that the genie is in the bottle is
because Suleiman Solomon
actually imprisoned all the genes in
these copper bottles and threw them into
the ocean so the Khalifa hears this
story and he decides he absolutely must
see one of these models you know so
there's a person at his court whose name
is valium even solid I don't know if it
matters but tallied actually means
something like the seeker and his
father's name Sahara means something
like simplicity or easiness
anyway this Talib you have to try to
remember his name it becomes important
later on Talib he says from oh yeah he
says my father was once on a sea voyage
to India in the Bhullar condition it
says to India other editions of the
stories say somewhere near Sicily he
came to a island where these black
Aboriginal Muslims had fishermen who
were constantly fishing up these bottles
so Talib says all you have to do is send
an expedition to you know to where these
bottles are and so the khalifa he
arranges for this he orders somebody
called amir musa eben you say he is the
ruler of upper egypt
actually this emir musa probably a
historical figure it's probably the same
person as somebody is usually called
amir musa eben Nasser who was a famous
astrologer magician in the medieval
period he also had a part in the
conquest of the Maghreb so the Khalifa
sends a letter to this man Amir Musa and
tells him to you know fit out an expert
care of an and to set out in search of
the bottles and there is a guide whose
name the Felipa mentions his name is of
the Sunnah D actually a Samba of this
summer even L kuddusi
may be somehow connected to al Koontz
Jerusalem this AB dishonored he's a wise
man who knows the roots of the desert he
sold that he's very reluctant to accept
this mission because he knows it's going
to be a long journey that may last for
years and it's going to be an arduous
and rigorous journey but eventually he
is persuaded and tallied is also coming
along and they set off from Upper Egypt
north-northwest towards the Libyan
desert they think that they're moving
toward the sea very soon after they
begin this journey the first of many
inscriptions turn up turns out that the
desert this is an important thing one
should know the desert is actually
littered with hundreds or maybe
thousands of inscriptions
that are buried in the sand or otherwise
hidden in the medieval period there was
somebody called Abu Farah jealous / Hani
who actually collected these
inscriptions that so they are story you
know it's like there's no end of these
inscriptions I think that they're the
original core of the story these poetic
texts no so they come upon a kind of
castle an abandoned castle their palace
big black building nobody's there but
there are inscriptions there in the
first inscription and it's in Greek
supposedly but fortunately up the son of
the guy he knows screams so they just
off the sand and he translated into
Arabic I'm going to read it to you it's
typical of the whole series so calm and
tada whoo badness anhu yep he ll multi
Latinas all goofy winter shiburin and
said it in filter B Kazumi oh a damn
Mountain African with the filter be
marginal hey Ana maja to be Halima
yesterday who for certain people they
made things then wept for the wealth
they relinquished
a fortress inside it the last word about
rich Lords meeting in the dust deaths
finished them off tore them asunder they
lost to the dust whatever they had
gathered as if for no more than a moment
they'd laid down their loads to take
rest then of a sudden moved on so once
this has been translated Emir Musa he
hears it from Abdus Samad
and he begins to cry and he eventually
breaks down and faints and passes out
but when he comes to he then records it
in his little notebook which is probably
how we have these inscriptions right
there's a lot of them in this this empty
palace I'll read you a bit of the second
one where he says how much pleasure they
had how much had they eaten before it
was their turn to be eaten in the dust
and so on and there are 400 tombs there
that no surprise there's an inscription
here probably the builder of the city
says in my ignorance I lunged at every
promise of safety and each escaped me so
pay heed to yourself while you are young
before you drink the fatal cup in no
time soil will be heaped upon you and
you will be the opposite of alive there
are lots and lots of these messages from
the dead and they always end with that
kind of an admonition something like pay
heed now is the time unless it's already
too late learn from me I had everything
I did everything I tasted everything I
was strong and rich and still nothing
could hold back the hand of death think
of yourself think of God you who have
come to this place think hard about what
you see here think of the accidents of
time and the tales that are told be not
seduced by the world in its finery is
crookedness and lies its vanities and
trifles word is a flatterer cunning and
Treach
it gives you a loan only to take it back
it's like the befuddlement of sleep the
dreamers dream the mirage of water that
the devil produces to lure the thirsty
to their death have no faith in this
world and no love for it for it will
always betray whoever trusts it and so
on and so on
in this inscription it's in a kind of
rhyming prose called such it's signed by
somebody called Koosh even shaddadi
even I had so the father of this man who
shot dad even had he was a famous figure
and he was actually the founder of yet
another famous ruined City said he
called Edom of the pillars also
well-known from the Arabian Nights and
this King he thought his wealth would
save him his own soldiers had to tell
him that they could do nothing against
the Lord of that gate that has no
gatekeeper says he bill Bob 11 laser
level the web and every time one of
these texts is translated Emir Musa
breaks down again and he copies the
inscription and they wander to the
palace finally they come upon a big
table there's an inscription on the
table it says the thousand one-eyed
Kings ate upon me and a thousand kings
with two good eyes all of them now
inhabit the grave and so I'm dishonored
and I've been Musa they take his table
but he soon they come to a horsemen made
of copper he's holding a spear in his
hand and there's an inscription which
says that if they rub his hand if if
they don't know the way to the city of
copper he will point the way so they do
this and the horsemen kind of whirls
around like this and points in a
direction
quite the opposite of where they were
heading of course and now they kind of
have to go to the city of copper I mean
you've got that kind of message so they
set off following that direction pretty
soon they come to a big black stone
pillar in which is imprisoned and a
fleet that's a kind of demonic figure
and afraid
so this afraid he's kind of lonely it
seems he just can't wait to tell
somebody his story and to chat about
this and that he reminds me actually if
somebody I once met in India years ago I
met this guy who had taken a vow of
silence and for some 30 or 35 years he'd
never uttered a single word but he was
dying to talk to people talk in the
sense that he would write words and
sentences in the sand with a stick you
know he was perhaps the most loquacious
person I ever met in my life
so this he freaked is kind of like then
he tells his story it's a kind of long
story in brief he was a servant of the
king of the sea now they could bow and
this King had a very beautiful daughter
the most beautiful woman in the world
and he also had an image an idol that
the King worshipped and this he'd faith
easy feet they're restless creatures
they roamed the world so one day he
found himself in Jerusalem and he told
Sulaiman Solomon about this beautiful
daughter so of course Solomon wanted her
immediately and he sent a message via
the safely to the king of this sea
saying break your Idol take on the true
religion and give me your daughter and
if you don't I'll come and destroy your
kingdom so he goes back he actually
enters into the stone Idol and speaking
through the stone he tells the king the
king of the sea that he should ignore
this message and so the king of the sea
he goes to war against Suleiman that's a
really bad idea
Suleiman comes with his hosts of
predatory birds you know and all kinds
of other mysterious creatures and they
completely liquidate the kingdom of the
sea and they also destroy the idol of
course and the
the daughter for Suleiman and Suleiman
having done that he knows apparently
what the fleet has done so he imprisons
him in this stone he's stuck there in
that stone for all eternity or until the
day of resurrection the end of time and
this particular affinity is also happy
to answer questions for example they
asked him how far is it to the city of
copper and he says it's very near and
they say and where can we find those
copper bottles in which the gene have
been imprisoned by Suleiman and he says
in the sea of in Kaka you have to
remember that name in katakana
so maybe the mission can be accomplished
after all and they move on
and indeed fairly soon they see in the
distance something black with two
parallel tall fires those are the towers
made of copper of the city of copper it
has steep walls when they get there they
circumambulated and they I mean it's a
huge city it has 25 gates but none of
them can be opened from the outside
these are gates that can only be open
from the inside
oh and of course they want to go inside
so I'm your Musa asks his carpenters to
make a big tall ladder which they're
gonna put against the wall and meanwhile
it takes them a month the carpet is a
while this is going on they climb a hill
nearby and they look over into the city
they can see looks like a very kind of
luxurious place but there's no sound no
sign of life we'll need the cries of the
owls and the Ravens
but you'll be surprised to hear there
lot of inscriptions on this hill and
there in Greek on seven white marble
tablets pretty much like the earlier
ones that you heard and I'm your Musa
sheds more tears and copies them down in
his notebook and when he comes down from
the mountain the narrator says the whole
world has
been painted before his eyes cats wat so
we're at Union by nine ninety so I'm
here mooses learning to see
and finally when the ladder is ready
they place it against the wall and the
man from the caravan is sent to climb
the wall and he gets to the top and he
stands there wonderstruck for a moment
and then they can hear him down below
they can hear him crying out you are so
lovely and then they see him jump down
into the city to his death so they send
another man and exactly the same thing
happens and a third and a fourth and so
on twelve men climbed the ladder and
each of them gets to the top and the
same thing happens they jump down to
their deaths
so finally of the summit the wise old
man says I've got to go up that ladder
no says Amir Moussa we can't let you do
that because if you die then all of us
will die but he insists he says the man
who has experience is not like someone
who has no experience so he climbs the
ladder and he gets to the top he looks
down he sees beneath him ten incredibly
beautiful ravishing young women and
they're in a kind of big pool and she
also deeply wants sorry to jump into the
into this pool but somehow he remembers
the verses from the Quran of taking
refuge in Allah Himself back also down
below Emir Musa was really terrified he
shouts up to him we don't do it he
shouts up him we belong to Allah and to
Allah we return and so yup this summit
he sits down on the wall and he laughs
and he chants these verses and he
describes what he was what he's seen and
then he begins to walk along the wall
you know the ramparts of the wall until
he comes to the two copper towers and
beneath the two copper towers there's
copper horsemen again stretching out his
hand and there's an inscription which
if they turn a certain pin in the copper
Horseman's body 12 times the gate will
open and that's what he does and once
he's opened that gate he then goes into
the city he's amazed by what he sees he
comes to another gate and there's a dead
chick holds the keys to all of the gates
so he opens these gates as a huge noise
and now anybody can enter the city
copper and they rush in well actually
not all of them because I'm here Moosa
is afraid that something might happen so
most of the part of the caravan is left
behind but a big group comes into the
city and they what they see is this very
luxurious place their palaces there are
marketplaces they're richly decked in
all the wonders of the world
there's bundles of silk and bundles of
cotton there are spices and jewels and
pavilions there are birds made of
emerald with their feet made of pearls
all of these wonders but there's no
living soul the people are there but
they're lying on slabs of stone or on
silk as if they were sleeping or resting
their bodies dried up their bones
decayed and there's a big Palace with
very intricate passageways plated with
gold and adorned with ivory and silk you
know if you want an image of this
there's a rather beautiful engraving by
William Harvey from the some time around
1829 if I'm not mistaken you can easily
find it if you just type in into Google
if you type in William Harvey city of
brass or come out it's a kind of image
of what 19th century Orientalist thought
this city would have looked like you
know so there's an inscription in the
palace the inscription says look well oh
man at what you see
take care before you move on prepare
food for the way the best you have to
suit your taste for anyone who lives at
home will surely depart anyone who lives
at home
for the department and so on so they
wander through this amazing city and
they find a fountain at the edge of the
fountain is a bejeweled throne and on
the throne sits a woman more beautiful
than any eye has ever seen with
brilliant gems on her forehead she's
covered in pearls she has a crown of
gold and her eyes look straight at you
as if she were alive remember it pally
even Sahil
so Thalia was there he's the guy who set
the whole thing in motion so he is the
one who notices that these eyes of this
beautiful woman are made of stone and
that she's there and she'll never be
able to return a greeting their two
slaves on either side of the throne or
maybe their dolls maybe they're dead
it's not clear one black one white
beneath them is one last inscription in
this elegant prose I just read you a
little bit of it in the name of Allah
the eternal Osun of Adam how ignorant
you are of the life span of hope
how inattentive to the rapid approach of
that final instant don't you know that
death is yours that he has already come
for you be ready to depart prepare
provisions in this world for the journey
which is about to start where is Adam
where is Noah we are the kings of India
and Iraq where is shaddadi Mahad I am
Todd born daughter of the Amalekites who
had what no other kings had done more
but some people here will know this Todd
Moore is one of the names for the Queen
of Sheba be lucky she's buried in the
city of Todd more according to evening a
lot here one of the famous biographers
of the medieval period I am Todd Moore I
ruled happily in vast wealth and
pleasure until death came knocking for
seven years there was no rain when all
food was exhausted and there was none to
be brought to be bought anywhere in our
world we locked the gates of the city
and lay down to die giving ourselves to
the judgment of God such as the story
nothing is left for the eye to see
but these faint traces I thought and at
the bottom there's a warning
whoever enters the city can take what he
wants but no one can touch what is on my
body so I'm here mostly rights all this
down but tallied but old ally he says
what does this mean you know we're not
supposed to touch her body she's dead
and so he actually tries to strip some
of the jewels off of her body and then
one of those mechanical slaves slaves I
don't know one of them they have swords
he cuts off his head and I mean Moosa
curses him for his foolishness and his
green and his greed so they've filled
their sex with whatever else they can
take and the caravan now proceeds and
eventually you know what they get to the
Seacoast once they're there they are
welcomed by a Black Muslim King they
reached a sea at the place that it's
called al Caracara which is where they
were supposed to go and this see they
explained to the king with that they're
looking for these copper bottles you
know he says yeah they come up all the
time he feeds them fresh fish actually
it's not exactly fish these are believe
it or not some kind of mermaids edible
mermaids
and he hosts them for several days
they're eating these mermaids he sends
his divers to bring up some of the
bottles they come back with a lot of
these models and they take 12 of them
and they also take some of the mermaids
with them to go back to Damascus because
Emir Musa he says the Khalifa he'll
probably find these mermaids much more
interesting than these copper bottles in
the end and they go back to Damascus it
takes some time and when they're there
they hand over the bottles and they
break one open and the genie comes out
and he's screaming at Allah now you know
they that's all very interesting to the
Khalifa but he likes the mermaids they
built them these special pools so that
they can live and breathe but and
they're filled with water of course
these
but the mermaids died because it's just
too hot and Emir Musa the leader of the
caravan he's had enough he's seen enough
maybe more than enough he begs the
Khalifa to relieve him of his duties and
to allow him to retire to Jerusalem of
course a Sharif to serve God and to pray
and there he dies and that's all we know
of the city of copper but what happened
to the agent guide the indispensable and
wise Abdus Samad
who i think we would have to say is
really some form of the storyteller
Allah knows all okay that's the story
now I'm gonna take about another 20
minutes is that okay yeah okay so I have
to say to you the I mean I have some
thoughts about what this story is all
about what it means and why it is in a
form that we have it I'll maybe give you
a little trailer to when I'll be saying
tomorrow tomorrow I'll offer some
possible direction but before we do the
there's I think it's important that you
should know some of the things that
people have written about this story and
what people have said and they're also
certain factual things that you might
like to know so for example we might
start by asking what is the most useless
question we could ask ourselves about
this phantasmagoric travelogue so how
about where is it can we find it on
Google Maps but actually as it happens
this question has a partial answer not
quite clear where the city of copper is
in essence in siege of Massah but on car
car that we actually know it's a place
near the old city of Leptis Magna and
the Libyan coast it's near what's called
a lesser serious the gulf of sidra and
you know there even the name
so katakana has survived and working
backwards that would mean that our city
this new property must be somewhere in
the Libyan desert somewhere off the
caravan rode that passes through the
oasis of Cairo on that's not [ __ ]
territory the English Patient you could
add that if you like to the list of
tentative intro texts that go with this
story I also have to tell you another
thing about in katakana so you know
there's a village in Israel it's a it's
perhaps I think it's the only
Palestinian village in Israel which has
retained its original Arabic name it's
called core core core core it's near
hadera very close to the coast and the
reason it's called Concord is that its
inhabitants it's originally Arab
inhabitants emigrated there from Egypt
in the early 19th century when Muhammad
Ali ruled over Palestine for about 20
years and these people came from a
village that had been also it also named
Caracara in Egypt but it was named after
the original village they retained this
tradition and the original village was
on the Libyan coast at Alcott car and
alkar car is now in Israeli Hebrew car
Corps so sort of twin city of Khedira
by sheer coincidence but that's what
happens when you deal with this kind of
story but sure coincidence my wife and I
spent a weekend there just a few months
ago unfortunately didn't occur to me to
see if I should fish for some of those
copper bottles anyway that's katakana
you can see that the story belongs to
the Maghreb even though there's that
tantalizing link to India that the Cairo
text the bhulok text tells us but it's a
mammogram bein nightmare adventure and
it's by the way firmly anchored in a
wide range of early medieval Arabic
sources now we have to make a
distinction between the literary version
of this story that we know from the
Knights and between other references to
copper City somewhere in the
maybe built by Solomon or by somebody
else there are many such references
tabary Massoud e-even of Pakeha Madani
there are many sources that mention this
copper city and in fact it's not only in
Arabic I said you earlier there's this
Armenian version actually several
versions in Armenian middle Persian
knows about a city of copper located
somewhere north of Iran it's mentioned
in the Bundestag and in other sustaining
sources and actually even in Boone Wang
at the very least earn edge of the Silk
Road gooey goo or manuscript turned up
which also seems to know about a city of
coppers situated similar to the North
East of course and the Alexander romance
in its Armenian version knows about such
a story in fact it looks as if this
whole huge area from Libya to India or
beyond
when including Central Asia had some
traditions about a lost city of copper
that you can't find by any map
among other famous old cities like that
so actually what we have in the story
from the Arabian Nights is some literary
reworking of material that was very well
known actually I think of it as a well
constructed rather polished literary
text which I'm going to be calling the
Vulgate of the Cairo and Damascus coffee
houses I'll tell you more about that in
a moment
here's another unhelpful question what
are the layers that went into the
composition of this text that's the kind
of question phonologists like to ask
themselves and if you like this kind of
thing it can tell you there's a pretty
good book about the Knights by scholar
called Mia Gerhart and she has offered
the following surgical analysis she says
there are three layers the expedition to
al-qaeda cotta in search of the cop we
were bottles as first second the episode
of the city of copper apparently she
says a secondary accretion and thirdly
several subsidiary narratives attached
to the ladder like the black castle the
imprisoned the afraid the seven tablets
on the mountain and so on all connected
to the theme she says of the
transitoriness of life and the
omnipotence of death which I suppose is
fair enough
so there is this added link to the
solomon suleiman material but
unfortunately that division it has this
effect of obscuring the place of solomon
imaginative core of the story even
though in the very oldest sources he is
connected to the city of copper in fact
i think this has to be wrong by the way
it must be the case that there is some
kind of residue of Solomonic legend
taken from Islamic and Jewish sources in
this story like in many of the Arabian
Nights and there's that reference to
Todd Moore who is Bill kiss the Queen of
Sheba with her riddles there's actually
a lot to say about Salomon it's
interestingly this story ends
in Solomon's own city in Jerusalem it's
if that were its home base all along so
another less mechanical way to begin to
probe the strands at work in our tale is
deposit an active Jewish Solomonic focus
and minimally a South Asian Indian focus
which is deeply engaged with and perhaps
mingled into Mediterranean Neoplatonic
ideas as I will try to show I mentioned
Abu inferential is fahan II with this
collection I leave a collection of
desert graffiti I want to meet one or
two of these so I mean you had a sample
from the Persian in the nights there's a
translation of this book he taught at
the Beluga bar by Patricia Crone and
shmuel moreh this major two short
samples here's one it's kind of graffiti
Rafi toe we have built and we shall
perish what we have built will only
survive us for a while
nothing indoors against time
except God when we do not see but who
sees us or here's another rather
plaintive lament I am among those who
keep an eye on time hoping for a day of
joy without being beguiled by the past
good luck to the speaker but the most
fascinating aspect of these inscriptions
like the ones in our story is they're
seemingly necessary lack of
synchronization in every instance the
burning inside arrives too late
in fact experience suggests that such
insight can never emerge on time
maybe time or death is always late or
out of sync you know there's a beautiful
poem by Szymborska I'll read you a
couple of lines from a wonderful poem
it's the poem called on death without
exaggeration she says there's no life
that couldn't be immortal if only for a
moment
death always arrives by that very moment
too late in vain it tugs at the knob of
the invisible door as far as you've come
can't be undone but still in our text
these travelers are warned to prepare
their provisions Zod for the Deathly
journey ahead as if there were some form
of tangible maybe spiritual sustenance
and nurture that could carry them across
the abyss can it let's assume for the
moment that the spiritual or mystical
angle can clear away the opacity that
seems to grow thicker with nearly every
sentence as we read on so sad this is
the provision for a journey it can
definitely refer to the inside and
discipline that a Sufi seeks to
cultivate in preparation for another
life and so is it possible that our
story is a kind of allegory that a wheel
that will literally means a first thing
going back to the first source some
allegory about a mystical journey
through the dark night of terror and
ignorance toward the light of knowledge
and redemption there's a very fine near
abyss and rush emori at Princeton he
wrote a beautiful captivating essay
about this story as beautiful as the
story
itself I think and he argues like that
he says the as if living corpses in the
city would be mementos of spiritual
starvation the failure to know the true
self and the journey itself is a gnostic
parable parable of the souls
exile in this world and it's yearning to
return to this source so I think it's a
little tempting to follow a morays lead
like the way they lost Wayfarers follow
up this summit but look what happened to
so many of them and I have a new friend
young Syrian Arab youth who lives in
Berlin his name is usman hajar I reached
him by very circuitous and serendipitous
ways turns out he wrote a master's
thesis about the story it's a very
interesting thesis I met him we talked
about it he also thinks that this story
is a kind of Suseela Sufi allegory and
he himself is a susi a Sufis
practitioner but I suppose I should
confess that I don't really believe in
allegory or I don't really like it very
much I guess I think allegory is almost
always disappointing it tends to flatten
and reduce the dangerous expressivity of
the original and I think there must be
another less dichotomous or dualistic
way to go and incidentally there's the
end of the story which seems to me to
resist any kind of spiritual reading
what about those human mermaids edible
mermaids who die at the end in Damascus
of the heat so in fact everything about
el canto car with its black king and his
fishermen and the endless supply of gene
locked in copper bottles all of it oh
this seems to me to tend more toward a
kind of surreal parody of into allegory
and the reader could easily ask herself
what she feels when the story slips
rapidly to its conclusion if all the
knots been untied the riddle is answered
or do we rise unsaid
unnerved and still bewildered from our
chairs there just a couple more things I
want to say first of all these verses
he's haunting verses where are they now
they look as if they were formed in the
mould of the medieval Latin laments that
we know from Spain will be sunt where
are they now and probably the most
moving of these lamentations is that
final one in prose spoken as it were by
the once ravishing Tod more the dead
Queen Queen general this Arabic is
relatively transparent unlike so much of
the medieval poetry and breathless
sadness on the edge of death strives to
leave at least some sign
nothing says Tadmor the dead Queen is
left for the eye to see but these faint
traces and since we're toying for the
moment with possible models and
precedents I think we have to call to
mind the pre-islamic and early classical
casitas the Arabic poems in which the
Bedouin lover returns to the dispersed
campsite where he first saw his beloved
she's gone forever
only the elephant traces a cloud remain
to intensify his nostalgia and to infuse
him with despair in some sense a
positive healing disparity one of the
poets this is a hadith even ELISA he
says nothing consoles you like despair
Elias Lika colossi once there was love
and life and hope nothing is left life
moves on so the city of coppers is in a
certain sense and extended naseeb that
lugubrious portion of the the caseta in
which this painful encounter with the
traces and emotional consequences are
described but if this link is relevant
as I think it must be then whatever else
our story is about Evanescence the
finality of death the faith born of
desperation it is also it seems about
love in fact that long episode of the
ìiî imprisoned in the stone pillar turns
ultimately on Solomon's trust
I'd love for this demons daughter for
the King of the oceans daughter and
that's a topless that we know from many
of the Solomonic legends and if there is
love buried in the city of copper what
kind of love would it be because
wherever we look in the text beginning
with the copper bottles in the sea there
are stark images of blockage and fatal
paralysis everyone we meet is trapped in
some container with no hope of escape
death may be no more than the most
common and prevalent kind of cage the
freedom to live and want and taste and
no lasts but a second an atomistic
moment and the human body itself a
diluted concoction of dust and water is
no different from the stone pillar of
the sealed walls of the city all of us
are stuck until we die when the state of
being stuck becomes total this then is
the deep and constant topic of the
inscriptions the low moan of the lament
crammed into these outer shells we can't
breathe not in life not in depth reading
the inscriptions always literally takes
away a mere mooses breath death one
might suppose does this more effectively
but the two states if that is what they
are are all too alike is how maurices
death can look very much like life and
the opposite is also true do the living
really live or are they two akin to the
simulacra that turn up at critical
moments those seductive maidens for
example who would lure men to their
deaths when they climbed the city walls
in any case life and death seemed to
overlap although from another
perspective the living are always on the
brink of nothingness a radical
intensification of their half dead a
priori state we should be interested in
that brink and we will see that the
Tamil version is something
to say that if life is a long series of
simulations of simulacra interacting
with other simulacra and of intersecting
mostly anachronistic and somewhat ironic
messages what can we say about a work of
art the copper city is itself a magnum
opus the extraordinary creation of its
Queen and her architects so she tells us
in the final inscription amazement
Wonder is a consistent theme in the
story usually linked with terror and the
savage scandal of dying but then the
story too at least in its linear
unfolding must surely also be a stifling
seal in sealed box in which we the
readers are imprisoned possibly forever
where we might think of it as a frozen
moment a temporal atom infinite in scope
and meaning self-limiting self mimicking
in another sense what does it take to
make this story or for that matter any
story any string of words and sounds
come alive it's just here the strong
translations might help so
in concluding today's lecture I guess
it's time for me to come clean and tell
you that I think this story like those
inscriptions in the desert is not so
much about dying as it is about living
in time as all of us do and I think the
story probably took shape I'm talking
about the literary text at a very
specific time and place somewhere in the
Islamic East especially the cities of
the Iranian cities of rye and bowels
maybe a few contemporaneous cities like
Baghdad and Basra and Cairo in the 9th
to 11th centuries this was a time when
the Islamic free thinkers of the
Methuselah in the early kalam were well
aware of both the Indian philosophical
schools and of the Mediterranean
especially the Neoplatonic Greek
thinkers and I think that the city of
copper as we know it arose in that
scintillating milieu and that it is at
its earliest core a lyrical coffeehouse
version of the first debates about time
and substance and conscience
consciousness in God that raged in Hasan
and elsewhere in those centuries
remember the frame story of the Arabian
Nights Shahrazad tells night after night
a story which leaves the king and
suspense so that he won't kill her the
next day it's all about somehow playing
for time is it not so here's a story
maybe an emblematic story of the Knights
it seems to take off from that point no
I think some of you maybe all of you
hopefully all of you got a copy of a
handout that I had prepared as you
walked into this room we're not going to
read it together now I'm gonna be
talking about these passages that you
have there tomorrow they come from Abu
Bakr a lousy whom I mentioned earlier
and from a nice my Ely philosopher
Nelson who saw these two had a kind of
ongoing debate they had very fascinating
things to say about time just to give
you a slight taste of the way this is
going to continue let me say the
following few words and then
we'll stop the city of copper is heavy
with time it's soaked in time also
desiccated through time actually it's
soaked with several distinct temporal
rhythms or modes which seem to collide
and become stuck inside each other
unable to move it's a place where people
lost in time the time of our everyday
experience completes to face with the
locked stuff of eternity that can only
open from the inside out
and what happens some of them die some
survive traumatized yet amazed but that
time they have entered for a long moment
as a strange and beguiling
and perhaps also horrifying nature it is
also strangely self-contained autonomous
free even from the constraints imposed
by God can we say more about this
startling form of time that is also in
some sense timeless moving at an
unfamiliar pace or rhythm opening from
the inside I think we can I'll try to do
that tomorrow thank you for listening
[Applause]
this this extraordinary performance an
extraordinary weaving of so many so many
strands and so many threads with with a
richness that rivals the story that
you're telling us about it really is it
reminds us that that some of the
greatest scholarship is is that is is
the is the work of master storytellers
David Schulman clearly is one of those I
can't wait for tomorrow we're gonna say
a question and answer for after
tomorrow's lecture I invite you all to
to interact with Professor Shulman at
the reception right now and maybe you
can ask him some questions personally as
we as we as we drink and eat a little
bit so thank you so much for coming come
back again at five tomorrow please and
we'll hear the rest of this fascinating
story thank you thanks
[Applause]
[Music]